email cables um and how cables transmit
data
okay now there's am there's a physical
principle and i choose the word physical
importantly like it's physics right
there's a physical principle at work in
um in
physical cables that allows them to
transmit data and here's the way it
works
if we want to transmit data we need some
kind of medium
okay and so far we've talked about the
fact that for instance
as i'm speaking to you right now i am
transmitting
vibrations uh through the air and so the
the medium is all of this
you know oxygen and nitrogen that's
flying around which very conveniently
um vibrates uh helpfully so that you can
hear what i'm saying
right if we somehow lived in a universe
where you know we didn't have gas
everywhere
but everything was just you know solid
objects they don't
they don't vibrate so well when i'm
trying to speak through you know my
vocal chords
uh and in the same way if we lived in a
vacuum if we were like
um if we were organisms that lived in
vacuums
right and by the way you're like
organisms can't live in vacuums that's
not true
some can very exotic ones but that's
beside the point if we lived in a vacuum
again i couldn't transmit signals to you
audibly
right because there's nothing to vibrate
so i would resort to well how would you
communicate with someone in a vacuum
okay good so you can see each other so
even though sound
which is vibrating air doesn't work to a
vacuum
light photons can travel through a
vacuum just fine okay
now what we've been talking about so far
is um
electricity so we need a medium for
electrical signals to travel
okay and since very very long time ago
we've known
that metal is a good medium
for electricity okay it's a good medium
for electricity it transfers electricity
very effectively okay in fact that's
what makes it a metal um and so we
actually give this a special name we say
that it's um
it's conductive right
it conducts electricity okay electricity
can pass through it i suppose in the
same way
using the same language right we could
say that air
conducts vibrations that
sort of makes sense that there's a
signal we want to send
okay uh electricity that's the signal
and we need a medium that can handle and
hold that signal
and send it along without any sort of
interference or anything like that okay
so therefore let's come back this is the
principle by which all cables transmit
data
they're a medium that can transmit some
kind of signal usually
electricity okay but
that creates a problem okay and these
two videos were talking about it what's
the problem
when you send electricity through a um
through a wire through any kind of metal
actually through any conductor what's
the problem
uh yes sort of what distance is a
problem
but why is this a problem it has to do
with these
two videos what were they talking about
they were talking about the relationship
between two different things
what were they people who were here okay
the idea that there's electricity
and there's magnetism which seem like
very different things to us
right one of them uh just sticks things
to a fridge and the other one hurts if
you touch it right
but actually we know that they're part
of one force
that's why we call it the
electromagnetic force okay so here's the
problem
number one when you've got electricity
going through this
it's generating let me get a different
color
it's generating a magnetic field okay
so as as it goes through magnetic fields
are being sort of given off
okay so why would that be a problem well
number one that means you're losing
parts of the signal
okay so that's kind of not good but
number two
you know if i want to send one single
long here no problems okay
but usually we don't just want to send
one signal we want to send lots of
signals
so here's another cable right now what's
going to happen is if we're trying to
send two different things
along these two different cables right
both of them are giving off
magnetic fields and they're getting off
different ones because they're sending
different signals
okay so you can see what's going to
happen here you know you guys get two
magnets
and as you push them together what
happens
if say they are opposite uh you know
we're pretty not not opposite
um uh if they were the same poles right
and you'd push them together they would
repel each other right in other words
these two magnetic fields are
interacting okay does that make sense
now that's kind of cool when you're
playing around with magnets right or if
you want to stick something to a fridge
but that's not so cool when you want to
transmit signals why not
remember the idea that there was
electricity
and a magnetic field right
so far we've said that when you've got
one
it produces the other yes
but in the same way and you might have
seen this in the very first video right
if you've got this one you're also
producing this
so these both interfere with each other
okay so
what's happening back up here one signal
is getting sent along and it's giving
off a magnetic field
okay but that means it's interacting
with this magnetic field changing it
which also changes the signal okay
that's a big problem
if you want to send things you don't
want the you know going along and then
getting changed by all kinds of things
and you don't even need another wire it
could be anything
you know anything which can uh have some
kind of magnetic interference here
is going to change your signal all right
so
what was the principle that electricity
can travel on this
medium because it's conductive but the
problem is
you've got this other force magnetism
which complicates things
okay because if you want to send a
signal you just don't
want any particular electricity you want
a specific
flow of electricity which is your signal
okay